we have a voicemail number it's two one
nine two david p our voicemail line is
made possible by our great friends over
at ling vist which is an app for
learning spanish french german and
russian it quickly learns your skill
level and uses artificial intelligence
to speed up the language learning
process you can try it for free no
credit card required ling vist comm
slash Pakman linguist with a v comm
slash Pakman okay here's today's voice
mail last week i had an audience
question which was david make the
strongest case you can against Bernie
Sanders and I even said in the segment I
am making the strongest case I can
against Bernie Sanders as many people
know he's one of my top contenders I am
merely doing what the person asked me to
do what are the strongest arguments
against Bernie and someone heard that
segment and is offended that I didn't
also say all the good things about
Bernie take a listen to this to this
voicemail hey David this is candy I'm an
attorney in Missouri and I just watched
your video what's the strongest
criticism of Bernie Sanders um I
understand you doing that hey hey why
not follow it up with strongest
arguments and sportive bunny you know
why not that to your advertisers not
when you do that
very disappointed David very
disappointed right so first of all I
don't know what advertiser you're
talking about but no one has said to us
David we will advertise on your show if
and only if you say the bad things about
Bernie and not the good things that's
not an advertiser we would ever accept
number one number two there was not even
an advertiser mentioned in that segment
on the show but more importantly
whenever we talk about the 2020
Democratic primary I talk about all of
the reasons to support Bernie Sanders
and how he's one of the top three
candidates that I'm looking at this is
the you know we the segment was about if
you had the steel man opposition to
Bernie Sanders what is it that you would
say every other segment that we do about
the 2020 primary
I talk about all of the great things
about Bernie Sanders and why I would
consider supporting him and voting for
him and this is where I feel people sort
of get unreasonable and then on top of
this over the weekend someone actually
canceled their paid membership because I
did a segment saying if I wanted to make
the case against Bernie what would I
identify as his weaknesses and they said
they're not going to support any show
that is against Bernie Sanders and it's
truly depressing I mean it's really
really depressing when that happens and
I've told you before that they're sort
of normal reasons people cancel
memberships financial reasons they just
started kind of moving away from
political shows or they're listening to
other stuff or whatever right I mean
it's all fine
but when someone writes to me and says
David you know I supported you until you
went against Bernie Sanders in that
segment it's a thought experiment okay
someone said David what are the
strongest arguments against Bernie
Sanders candidacy we just want to hear
what what you think they are and to
interpret that as a smear it's
depressing and whenever this happens I
kind of get bummed out and I honestly I
start questioning like the hell am i
doing is this is our things so
hair-trigger
that if I merely explore how I would
argue against the Bernie candidacy
people are pulling financial support
just disappointing I guess I don't know
what other word to assign to it we've
got a great bonus show for you today for
people who still are members and have an
angrily cancelled because I considered
how I might argue against a Bernie
Sanders candidacy the White House is
working on health care plans with three
conservative think-tanks will talk about
that we have a sort of string of minor
injuries and blocked sidewalks that are
now becoming a real nuisance as a result
of the prevalence of electric scooters
around the country and I also want to
tell you about the Colorado sheriff
who's willing to go to jail rather than
enforce a gun law that has been proposed
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show become a member
become a patron to get instant access
and I'll speak to you then